come on
[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Jean
Ross Hello friends Pastor Doug
batchley's away this weekend but this is
a live interactive International Bible
study and if you have a Bible related
question we would love to hear from you
this evening but why don't we start the
program with an amazing fact the record
for hiding away from family and friends
was made by young Chinese college
student by the name of Ching Lim he was
studying engineering at the University
of Michigan but was doing very badly in
physics and math
if his studies did not improve he would
have to leave school quit his job as the
janitor at the Ann Arbor First Methodist
Church and take the humiliating news of
his academic failure back to his father
who was a school teacher in Singapore
finally one day in October 1955 Chang
disappeared his friends including the
Reverend Eugene Ransom pastor of the
church called the police but they found
no clues
Chang's Methodist friends had another
mystery to ponder strange bumping noises
that came out of the church at night
early one morning four years after
Chang's disappearance a pair of private
detectives called by Reverend Ransom
heard a trapdoor to the church attic
slam together with the police they
climbed up and they swept their
flashlights across the attic and there
crouched above them in the rafters was
Chang
for four years the attic of the church
had been his home the bumping noises had
been changed skipping rope to keep in
shape during the day he slept on padding
from a Pew and at night he walked around
the church and helped himself to food
from the church kitchen
physically Chang seemed unaffected by
his homeless experience but as the
police hold him off to County Jail his
four-year preoccupation with loss of
face suddenly vanished I've been a
coward he said I'm glad I was found
well did you know friends that the Bible
speaks of a time when the devil will be
forced to sort of live the life of a
Hermit and the Bible tells us in
Revelation chapter 20 beginning in verse
then I saw an angel coming down from
heaven having the key to the bottomless
pit and a great chain in his hand and he
laid hold of the dragon that Serpent of
old who is the devil and Satan and bound
him for a thousand years and cast him
into the bottomless pit and shut him up
and set a seal on him that he should
deceive the Nations no more till the
thousand years were finished but after
these things he must be released for a
little while
so here we find the Bible speaking of a
time when the devil is bound in
something called the bottomless pit now
if you study that subject out you
actually discover that the bottom of the
spirit is really a reference to the
Earth in a broken down desolate
condition after the second coming of
Christ now we have a study guide that
talks about this 1 000 year time period
that you find in Revelation chapter 20
sometimes referred to as the Millennium
which literally means a thousand years
it's called a thousand years of peace
that is our free gift and we're happy to
send that to anyone here in North
America if you'd like to receive the
gift all you need to do is call the
number
800-835-6747 and you can ask for offer
number one two three or ask for the
study guide by name it's called a
thousand years of Peace we'll be happy
to send that to anyone here in North
America if you're outside of North
America and I know we have a number of
folks who are tuning in from different
countries around the world we encourage
you to go to the Amazing Facts website
just amazingfacts.org org or.com and
you'll be able to download the study
guide and read it for free right there
online well as mentioned a little
earlier Pastor Doug is out this evening
and so working the phones we have a new
face to Bible answers live we go past
the Aaron Cruz who is joining me here
and we're just delighted that Pastor
Cruz is here now Pastor Chris you new to
California and you've just joined the
Granite Bay pastoral team right here and
so we work together we are colleagues at
the church uh prior to you coming to
California I think you've been here what
about a month if that
almost two almost two months okay prior
to that you were doing pastoral work and
where were you located I was located in
uh Michigan I pastored in Michigan for
almost seven years all right and I know
we have a number of folks who listen uh
in Michigan so they might even some of
the people might even know you from that
part of the world but we're just
delighted to pass the air and he's with
us and joining us he's also got a
wonderful wealth of Bible knowledge and
so he'll be joining me as we answer
these various Bible questions and look
at them up if you have a Bible question
uh the number to call here to the studio
is
800-463-7297 again that's
800-463-7297 that'll get you in the cube
we have a number of folks who are
waiting for there for us to take their
questions so we're going to get to it
right away but Pastor Cruz before we go
to the phone lines uh would you start
the program with prayer absolutely let's
pray together
dear heavenly father thank you for the
opportunity to be alive today and to
have Minds to think critically about
what your word says Lord open our minds
to to hear your answers from your word
this evening we pray in Jesus name amen
amen
all right well past the Aaron let's go
to our first caller for this evening who
do we have
all right we have Philip Philip from
Arkansas
Philip hi welcome to Bible answers live
what is your question today
hi good evening pastors
there's a prophecy in Hosea 6 2 it's
part of an interesting passage there
but I was wondering have you guys ever
applied that to anti-prophecy especially
if you assign one day for a thousand
years okay well good question uh let me
read it so those of you who are
traveling in your car you might not have
your Bible in front of you uh Hosea
chapter 6 verse 2 says after two days he
will raise us up and on the third day he
will raise us up sorry let me re-read
that I messed it up after two days he
will revive us I need to add on the
third day he will raise us up that we
may live in his sight now it's
interesting when you look at this
prophecy here in Hosea we have a time
period after two days and then on the
third day we'll be raised up it's a
reference to Israel that's the most
immediate context and deliverance that
will come to God's people but I think
it's quite clear that this is a prophecy
not only related to literal Israel but
it's also prophecy related to Christ
because Christ rose from the dead on the
third day it's also interesting that I
believe Hosea Pastor Cruz mentions that
Israel came up obviously as we know out
of each Egypt but there's also a
prophecy with reference to Christ and it
says I called my son out of Egypt and of
course we know Jesus when he was still a
baby just before Herod slaughtered the
babies in the area of Judea that Joseph
directed by an Angel took the family
down into Egypt and then Jesus was
brought up out of Egypt so we see a
parallel between ancient Israel and we
see a parallel with that in the
experiences of Christ and in particular
we have a prophecy here that refers to
Christ's death and his resurrection of
course Jesus also speaking of his death
he says tell that old Fox speaking of
Herod that I work today tomorrow and the
third day I'm a perfected or completed
so we do have a number of references but
I think this is a clear reference here
to the death burial and crucifixion of
Christ is that helpful
yeah yeah I get what you're saying but
if you apply a day for a thousand years
to it you could see where the third
millennium would be after 2 000 years
since Christ baptism we would be
starting that third millennium when
Jesus would raise up yeah no I think you
yeah I think you're on to something for
sure you know Peter tells us that one
day with the Lord he says a thousand
years and a thousand years he says a day
uh we know the Earth he's inhabited for
about 6 000 years and then Jesus comes
and then we have that 1 000 year
Millennium or that 1 000 year Sabbath
and we actually spoke about that in the
opening so we believe that we're living
very close to that 6 000 year mark and
soon Jesus will come and for the
redeemed they will be raised up they
will live in the presence of God so I
think you can apply uh this prophecy to
Final Redemption as well as to Christ
amen all right great question thanks for
calling Philip
all right who do we have next all right
next we have Dennis calling in from
Minnesota hi there Dennis what's your
question today hello Pastor rossen
Master Cruz
I've been wondering for a long time
on Genesis 3 when the Earth's got cursed
because of sin by uh by Jesus Christ
it's obviously been deteriorating ever
since you know with the flood and all
and it seems like our solar system seems
to be too because the sun doesn't seem
to be as powerful as it was even in my
70 years of existence
um is the rest of the whole universe and
or the solar system that we live in the
uh cursors just the Earth or is it you
know the rest of the creation you know
that's a good question I mean the Bible
specifically mentions after the fall of
Adam and Eve that God cursed the Earth
and most specifically the ground for
man's sake and It produced thorns and
thistles but what about the rest of our
environment could that also have
affected uh was affected by sin well you
know if you look at our solar system it
does seem that uh you know we live in a
solar system that to some degrees
there's violence you have asteroids you
have the surface of the Moon that is
kind of broken down Mars it's got storms
that rage on the on the surface of Mars
the Bible does not specifically say more
than just our Earth but it is possible
that our Earth is sort of surrounded by
these planets we have the Sun at just
the right distance so that we could have
life on Earth it seems as though our
little solar system was created and set
up just for Earth so could the
consequences of what's happened here on
Earth spell out to at least those those
planets within our solar system possibly
although the Bible does not directly
come out and say that but it is an
interesting observation it's a good
point
well thanks for call Dennis thank you
all right who do we have next
we have Angela calling in from Illinois
hi there Angela what is your question
hello
um hi Pastor Ross hello and Pastor Cruz
um Exodus 24
9-11 and it talks about Moses and Aaron
and nadab and abihu and the 70 elders
and but in verse 10 it says and they saw
the god of Israel
did did they actually see
did they see God
well they saw him at a distance
um they they didn't see him closely I
mean they saw him at a distance just as
the children of Israel to some degree
saw God in the fiery Cloud that came
down on Mount Sinai they saw enough of
God to actually describe at least what
he was on because it says if you read
the verse there it talks about under his
feet there were paved works of sapphire
stone like the very heavens in its
Clarity so they they had a picture of of
God's glory but it was at a distance and
I think they didn't clearly see the face
of God because the Bible tells us no man
can see God and live and when it came to
Moses he was a lot more righteous than
these gentlemen uh God said you can't
see my face but I'll put you in the
cleft of The Rock and I'll pass by and
you'll at least see my back so yes they
did see God but at a distance they
couldn't see the direct features of God
maybe there was a glory shining forth
that appears that way a light shining
forth from God they witnessed him Seated
on his throne and the paving Stone
oh okay thank you all right great
question thank you Angela okay bye
bye-bye
all right next we have a caller uh Jerry
calling in from Texas hi there Jerry
welcome to the show
hey Pastor Chris and Pastor Ross I
always ask Grace in question
I appreciate that mentioning about
my question I guess relates to Exodus 25
8. before sin existed was there a
sanctuary in heaven we know that Lucifer
and probably Gabriel said and sat upon
the throne of God no covering the
covering cherubs but was there a
sanctuary before sin existed okay good
question well we know there are parts of
the sanctuary that existed forever for
example God's law the foundation of his
government that uh you know in the
Earthly which is a shadow of the
Heavenly you have the Ark of the
Covenant with the mercy seat that serves
as the Throne of God at least in the
most holy Place unto which are the Ten
Commandments which form the foundation
of God's government that was always in
existence the the tables of stone that
were placed in the Ark of the Covenant
was a copy of the great original that
was in heaven however the functioning of
the sanctuary prior to sin God's throne
room but you know there was a
modification you might say that took
place because everything that was
revealed in the sanctuary as it relates
to Moses was to point forward to the
Plan of Redemption and how God was going
to save mankind all the way from the
work of the priest to the sacrifice to
the various articles of furniture in the
sanctuary and then of course the
movement of the priests the high priest
into the most holy place for a judgment
and then he was going to come out from
the temple on the day of atonement he'd
lay his hands on the scapegoat which
would be taken to the Wilderness so all
of that ties into the work of redemption
it is interesting to also note that
during the 1000 years we know that the
Heavenly Sanctuary is in heaven but in
the earth made new when everything is
created the end of Revelation and John
describes that he saw no Temple therein
well this is after the Earth is
recreated in other words the the work of
the sanctuary has met its ultimate
fulfillment the purpose of which was to
bring Redemption to people that doesn't
mean there's a demolition of the
sanctuary but its function is now
complete it served its purpose so God
has a throne room God has a dwelling
place it's always been maybe there was a
modification to that throne room for the
Plan of Redemption and then we find that
after all things are made new at the end
of the Thousand Years the Earth is
recreated there is no need for a
sanctuary to function because sun is
being taken care of
does does that help
that wasn't a law then well you know if
you think about it there's a principle
that governs all of God's law the first
four Commandments have to do with love
for God the last six have to do with
love for a fellow man now it's true
adultery was not the sin related to the
angels but that was definitely a sin
that could be related to Mankind and
there are other intelligent beings we
believe that you know Adam and Eve and
the inhabitants of Earth were the only
ones that could procreate in their own
image and that was unique so yes that
commandment relates to us but I think
there is a spirit spiritual application
that of betrayal and of course Lucifer
is guilty of that he betrayed his trust
to God or trust in God so the principles
of love for God love for a fellow man is
of course the foundation of which God's
government is based oh you guys have
such knowledge of course it's given to
you by the holy spirit thank you guys
continue to do your work well thanks for
calling Jerry we happy we can share and
we're all learning together
we uh like studying and there's always
something new to learn friends if you
have a Bible question the number to call
is
800-463-7297 again that's
800-463-7297 if you have a Bible related
question and we'll be happy to take your
call on the air
past the cruise who do we have next
yeah next we have Gregory calling in
from Mississippi hi there Gregory
hey
thanks for calling me yeah yeah hi
what's your question Greg
my question is is it okay to go fishing
on the Sabbath okay is it okay to go
fishing on the Sabbath well
um let me put it this way it is okay to
be in nature on the Sabbath but on the
Sabbath we want to lay aside our own
personal interests or activities that
would take away from centering upon
Christ and upon worship so yes when
you're in nature and you're witnessing
the beauty of Nature and the Beautiful
creation around you that's a good thing
to do on the Sabbath but if your focus
is on trying to catch the big fish
um that's probably not the right
activity to do on the Sabbath focusing
on fishing or maybe somebody wants to go
surfing on on Sabbath and they say well
I'm in the ocean yeah you know nature
with the waves so there are certain
activities that we want to lay aside on
Sabbath so that all of our focus our
attention could be on what the Sabbath
principles are that is rest that is an
opportunity for us to build a
relationship with our fellow man our
family but also to worship that's the
centrality of the Sabbath he's
worshiping God worshiping the Creator so
I I would say you know I'm not a Fisher
are you do you fish Aaron I I I don't
fish okay no I know that it's a pretty
compelling Sport and a lot of folks
enjoy doing that but you know just
knowing other sports that people can be
involved and that's probably not the
activity that one wants to be engaged in
on Sabbath do that on another day of the
week
yeah something I want to add is uh when
there's ever questions regarding the
Sabbath I like to go back to the command
itself right and build whatever answer
that we're developing from the actual
text so if we turn to Exodus 20 verses 8
through 11 I'll just kind of read
through some of the the fourth
Commandment here it says remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy right just
as Pastor John was saying right the
emphasis is on this day is different
it's God's day it's God's day right so
if there's commonplace things uh that
you do the other six days perhaps
fishing is one of those things then
maybe on the the seventh day you want to
say hey I want to treat this day holy
because it's God's day and do something
a little different and the command goes
on six days you shall labor do all your
work with the 70s the Sabbath the Lord
your God in it you shall do no work you
nor and then it goes on to give a long
list so to me the the the summary of the
fourth Commandment uh is the day should
be treated holy uh and then it's a day
to be treated and kept restfully right
but it's a two-fold rest you take rest
and then you give rest you extend rest
to those within your sphere of influence
right the The Stranger Within your Gates
your children even animals even your
animals right get arrested we apply
these principles right I think we can
think through any question about the
Sabbath and find an answer all right
well thank you Gregory that's a good
practical question that a lot of people
are wondering about what what is
appropriate to do there on the Sabbath
you know we do have a study guide for
anyone wanting to learn more about the
Sabbath is it still binding on
Christians in the New Testament we have
a study guide called The Lost day of
History it's free we'll send it to you
all you have to do is call
800-835-6747 and we'll be happy to put
in the mail and send it to you again
that study guide is called The Lost day
of history and you know Pastor Cruz we
have a website that amazing facts has
put together it's called Sabbath
truth.com and it's just jam-packed with
great resources there's sermons there's
Bible studies there so if you want to
learn more about what does the Bible say
about the Sabbath take a look at the
website it's sabbathtruth.com I think
you'll find it very interesting we got
who's our next caller
Terence is that Terence in North
Carolina we've got Terence hi there are
you there Terence
yes Pastor Cruz how are you hi I'm doing
well welcome to the show what's your
question today
uh question Professor Cruz and Pastor
Ross's Revelations 2010
um
and the devil who deceived them was
thrown into the lake of burning sulfur
where the Beast and the false prophet
had been thrown they will be tormented
day and night forever and ever and my
question is is that literally forever
and ever or is that just uh
figurative language no I think it's
literal they're going to be tormented
forever and ever until they are no more
now I want to make that clear you know
the Bible tells us that the wages of sin
is death and in the Judgment everyone is
rewarded according to their work so not
everyone receives the same punishment so
some will suffer a little longer before
they are completely destroyed in the
Lake of Fire and the Devil Himself being
the author of sin and suffering he'll
probably suffer the longest but all
Sinners including the devil and his
angels they come to an end and they are
destroyed because the the fires that
destroy the wicked eventually go out
because it says God creates a new
heavens and a new Earth and the Lake of
Fire actually takes place on the earth
if you read in Revelation chapter 20 it
talks about the wicked mounting their
attack upon the New Jerusalem the Golden
City and Fire coming down and devouring
them so that occurs on the Earth but
once the fire is accomplished its work
and they are forever no more they are
destroyed forever and ever they can
never be resurrected then the fire of
course has done its job and God is able
to recreate the Earth so forever and
ever means as long as life shall last
now we're not talking about you know
long ages of suffering here it appears
at least a day and a night that they'll
be suffering and I you know the Bible
doesn't say how long it's not going to
be a long time because God's going to
create a new Earth and you're not going
to have the wicked suffering forever but
they they will receive a just penalty
for their for their actions uh does that
does that help Terence
this does thank you very much Pastor
Ross all right great good question you
know we have a study guide actually the
one I think we offered called a thousand
years of Peace touches on that a little
bit because the whole subject there he's
talking about Revelation chapter 20. and
we also have another study guide called
is the devil in charge of how you know
Pastor Cruz this is a subject that has
brought a lot of confusion to people
it's verses like this that you say well
how long do the fires of Hell burn do
they burn Without End well you've got to
put a number of Bible verses together
but the Bible makes it pretty clear that
the wicked are destroyed the wages of
sin is death Jesus said we have two
choices we can have everlasting life or
we have death it's not life in a place
of Torment throughout eternity it's
death so yes there is a fire there is a
Hellfire the wicked are destroyed in the
fire they do suffer according to their
works but they all are destroyed the
Bible says that the wicked return to
ashes yeah in fact there's one verse in
particular
um that's directly I believe related to
Revelation 20 verse 10 which has as its
focus the devil right if we turn back to
Ezekiel chapter 28 there's a prophecy
concerning the devil right about his
fall uh from heaven and it says here in
Ezekiel 28 verses 18 and 19 it says I
turned you to ashes speaking of the
devil upon the Earth in the sight of all
who saw you verse 19 all who knew you
among the peoples are astonished at you
you have become a horror and you shall
be no more forever now that's a pretty
clear verse talks about the devil so
it's not just talking about you know bad
people here but he's talking about the
Devil Himself the author of sin that
he's turned to ashes and it tells us
where it's on the earth and then it
tells us all these final fate you shall
be no more well you know that's good
news for the believer we're not always
going to have to deal with the great
tempta the adversary the one who is
causing sin and suffering and pain the
Bible also speaks about God wiping away
every tear from the eyes of those who
are saved so the time comes where
there'll be no more pain and God will
make all things new and friends the most
important truth that we can understand
is that Jesus has made a way of
Salvation none of us need to be outside
that City of Gold when those fires fall
and the wicked are destroyed through
Christ and through his atoning sacrifice
we can have everlasting life and friends
that's good news if you'd like to learn
more about how you can make sure that
your heart is right with God and that
you can receive the gift of eternal life
it will encourage you to call and ask
for our study guide It's called ultimate
deliverance and it's talking about
salvation ultimate Deliverance that
comes through Christ through what he has
done for us and that's really good news
so yes there is a judgment the wicked
will be destroyed there is a hell it
does not burn people forever
but then God creates a new heavens and a
new Earth and you know that's good news
that we find in the Bible God is going
to make all things new amen well friends
if you have a Bible related question and
the number again is
800-463-7297 I'm looking at the clock
past there and we don't have time to
take another call we're coming up on our
mid-show break but we still got another
half an hour of Bible questions so if
you've got a question about the Bible
just call us and we have a couple of
lines that are open so there's a good
time during our break to give us a call
the number is
800-463-7297 now I'd mentioned just a
little a little earlier that Pastor Doug
is out of town today and you might be
wondering well where is he pass the Doug
and Pastor Carlos sometimes also helps
with Bible answers live they're actually
in Mexico City both this weekend and
next weekend and they doing a special
Revival series that will be broadcast
it's actually going to be broadcast and
Pastor Doug's going to be preaching
Pastor Carlos will be translating to
Spanish for him and that's going to be
taking place on 3ab and Latino and it's
going to be later in the week I think it
starts on Wednesday evening so friends
if you interested in that we want to
encourage you to check out 3abn Latino
they're going to be carrying it live
it's going to be a great Revival series
actually coming from Mexico City one of
the most densely populated one of the
largest cities on the earth so make sure
you tune in and find out more about that
again if you have a Bible question the
number is
800-463-7297 or we're not ending the
program we're just going to take a short
break and we'll be back in a few minutes
to ask to answer your Bible questions we
also have some interesting information
and some announcements that we'll be
showing you during the break so don't go
too far away we'll be back in about a
minute and a half
foreign
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
feel as though your world is spiraling
out of control or perhaps new life
challenges are frightening you more than
they should are you sinking while you're
thinking excessive worry can consume you
eating you from the inside out resulting
in sickness insomnia and paralyzing fear
it can also damage relationships ruin
opportunities and yes diminish your
witness for the gospel worry affects
everybody differently but it's all
driven by fear
so how can you overcome a world full of
reasons to be anxious I'd like to
recommend for you my new book Finding
peace in a world of worry you'll
discover a Lifeline to Victory a place
where you can cast your cares upon
Christ and experience a Serenity that
isn't subject to your circumstances send
the gift of any amount to receive your
copy of Pastor Doug's new book Finding
peace in a world of worry call
877-232-2871 today are you wondering
what lies ahead in human history
landmarks of Prophecy offers clear
answers to your most pressing questions
presented by Pastor Doug Batchelor
landmarks of Prophecy as a video Bible
study Adventure designed for today's
audiences presenting The Landmark themes
of the Bible in a compelling way giving
you knowledge to face the future with
confidence start your ethic Bible study
adventure with landmarks of Prophecy
today by calling
800-538-7275 or by visiting AF bookstore
dot com
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7 pm
and 8pm Pacific time to receive any of
the Bible resources mentioned in this
evening's program call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now let's rejoin our hosts
for more Bible answers live
Hello friends welcome back to Bible
answers live my name is Pastor Jean Ross
and joining me is pasta Pastor Cruz past
Aaron Cruz is joining me on the phone
we're glad he's here a new face to those
of you who watch Bible answers live on a
regular basis and we are delighted that
he's helping out this evening and I'm
sure we'll be seeing him again during
our upcoming Bible answer Live program
now if you have a Bible question we got
one line open that I can see so give us
a call it's
800-463-7297-800-463-7297 we also want
to greet those who are watching on AF TV
amazing facts television also those
listening on the various land-based
radio stations also on satellite radio
and also uh we have a number of folks
watching on I believe the internet
YouTube and Facebook and so we want to
welcome all of you and also those who
are watching the program in the
rebroadcast phase on various other
networks so Pastor Cruz who's our next
caller
yeah we've got Robert calling in from
Washington is that Washington DC or
Washington State Robert
Washington State North West pocket here
all right well welcome what is your
question
well I
I hear quite often as I'm on Facebook uh
mainly that a lot of people believe that
Christ is going to set up his Earthly
Kingdom you know the Millennium will be
here on Earth
um
and you know of course they've got their
bible verses to explain that
um so how would
how would you go about saying that well
you're wrong it's we go up okay well
good question well you know if they've
got Bible verses that explain somehow
that Christ is going to rule here on
this Earth over the wicked during the
Thousand Years I'd like to see that it
is true the Bible does speak about
Christ ruling on the earth no doubt
about that but the sequence of how
things play out the Bible's pretty clear
let me begin with one verse the great
promise in John chapter 14 Jesus said
let not your heart be troubled you
believe in God believe also in Me In My
Father's House there are many mansions
aware in my father's house where's the
father's house well it would be in
heaven in my father's house there are
many mansions if it were not so I would
have told you I go to prepare a place
for you in the father's house and if I
go and prepare a place I will come again
unto my unto you to receive you unto
myself that where I am there you may
also be so at the second coming of
Christ Jesus is coming to take the
redeem to the place that he has prepared
for them in the father's house or that
of course would be in heaven so when
Jesus comes the second time there are
several things that take place the
righteous are changed the living the
righteous living are changed in a moment
in the twinkling of an eye they get
their Immortal bodies the dead in Christ
are resurrected and they are caught up
to meet the Lord in the air and Christ
takes them to heaven the wicked are
destroyed with the brightness of Christ
coming in first Thessalonians speaks of
that as well as Revelation chapter 19
near the end so the wicked all destroyed
with the coming of Christ the righteous
are taken to heaven 1 and for a thousand
years the righteous are in heaven and
they're involved in judging the Bible
refers to them as ruling the aspect of
rulership that's so significant is that
of judgment and they're involved in
judging the wicked even the angels the
wicked Angels during that Thousand Years
not determining who saved and lost God
does that but that has something to do
with reaffirming the decision that God
has made but also the rewards of all the
judgments that come upon the wicked and
then at the end of the Thousand Years
according to Revelation chapter 21 it
describes the New Jerusalem coming down
from God prepared as a bride adorned for
a husband and then Jesus sets his foot
on the Mount of Olives which is in
Zechariah it opens up and forms a great
Valley and the New Jerusalem comes to
rest and all the wicked are then
resurrected for the great white Throne
judgment that you read about in
Revelation chapter 20. at the end of
that I'm just giving you a synopsis at
the end of that great white Throne
judgment the way could actually mount an
attack upon the Golden City fire comes
and devours them then the Earth is
recreated and the righteous then will
inherit the earth that's the promise the
meat shall inherit the earth so they're
not ruling over the wicked during the
Thousand Years here on the earth they're
in heaven and at the end of the thousand
years is the final great white Throne
judgment
yeah a couple things at it and that's a
great summary of the Thousand Year
period here in Revelation 20 verse 5 it
says that the dead speaking of the
wicked dead it says did not live again
until the thousand years were finished
right so here on the earth there's no
humans alive right then what we see
right before Revelation 20 in Revelation
19 this is a picture of the second
coming Jesus is coming on a white horse
with a sword symbolically coming out of
his mouth king of kings Lord of lords
this is the the second coming and we
know from the rest of scripture at the
second coming that's when all of the
righteous are resurrected go to heaven
so when it says they reign with Christ
for a thousand years this rain uh
happens in heaven while the wicked are
sleeping they're they're dead they're
resting yes awaiting them because people
wonder well who they reigning over it
they're reigning with Christ for a
thousand years and the point that I want
to emphasize the most significant part
about reigning when a king sat upon his
throne and he was reigning he was acting
as a judge it was a judgment so the
redeemed will be involved in a judgment
during the Thousand Years Paul says no
you're not that you shall judge Angels
how much more things pertaining to this
life so anyway there's just a quick
overview hopefully that helps Robert you
might want to get the study guide called
a thousand years of Peace it's just
jam-packed with scripture and I think
you'll find an interesting study who do
we have next
all right next we have Jerry calling in
from uh California our very own State hi
there Jerry what is your question
tonight
so actually that call prompted another
question sure uh
so that question is what do you guys
think is the timing of or do you even
believe in the Rapture as
pre-tribulation post-tribulation okay
good question well of course the word
rapture does not appear in the Bible but
the idea of being caught up that's where
it comes from to the raptures to be
caught up the Bible is clear that when
Jesus comes the dead in Christ are
raised and the living together are
caught up to meet the Lord in the air
and maybe you can look that verse up in
first Thessalonians
um so the Lord comes Jesus comes the
second time the dead are resurrected the
righteous are changed and together we
are caught up to meet Jesus in the air
but the wicked are destroyed with the
brightness of Christ coming so the
wicked all dead so the Rapture occurs at
the second coming of Christ which occurs
when Jesus comes the second time so
there is a tribulation a Bible in Daniel
chapter 12 verse 1 talks about a
terrible time of trouble that is worse
than the world has ever been but that
precedes the second coming of Christ and
that's when the several last plagues are
poured out that you read about in
Revelation chapter 16. now God's people
are protected during that time God
provides for them we need not fear God
will take care of his people but they're
on the earth just like the children of
Israel were in Egypt when the plagues
Came Upon Egypt and then they were
delivered out of Egypt and they went to
the promised land so the righteous will
be on the Earth when the plagues come
during this time of trouble but they are
protected and they are delivered out
from the earth and they go to heaven for
a thousand years so that's kind of the
context there Jerry does that does that
make sense
so I guess you guys believe
post-tribulation right we believe that
the time of trouble precedes the second
coming of Christ
it happens uh pre-tribulation but I'll
move on to my next question sure so my
original question sorry that change up
oh no problem
uh so my original question is can we
lose our Salvation okay well it's
probably up to us you might say
um if we're trusting in Christ the Bible
says that no one can pluck us out of the
father's hand actually Jesus said that
so if we're trusting in Christ and we
have a living relationship with Jesus we
need not fear we're safe and secure but
when one receives salvation accepts
Jesus as his personal savior his Free
Will doesn't go away we still have
freedom to choose so we can choose and
the Apostle Paul says I Die daily it is
a daily surrendering of ourself to
Christ
um we can unfortunately if we choose we
can walk away God's not going to force
us to be saved if we no longer want to
be saved right I mean we have that
freedom of choice but if we are choosing
him and surrendering to him uh we need
not fear we are secure he's going to
hold us in the palm of his head yeah and
I think sometimes the the question asks
can you lose your salvation sometimes
it's like a pen right can you lose your
pen it's sometimes we view salvation as
an item something that's oh I dropped it
we have to remember that salvation is a
relationship we get it through a
relationship with Jesus right and as you
were mentioning earlier God doesn't take
away our Free Will right once you're
married or once you're in a relationship
with someone for you to say ha I've got
you now you can never leave me right
God's not like that he's not going to
force you to stay right so salvation can
be lost in the sense of someone can walk
away from a relationship with Jesus yes
now I don't know why somebody would want
to do that but I mean they they are free
to do that
um although Christ doesn't want us to do
that yeah and one more helpful thing I
think if you read the book of Hebrews
you find all throughout the Book of
Hebrews lots of warning passages about
walking away from Christ one of them is
in Hebrews 3 verse 14 where it says for
we have become partakers of Christ
notice if we hold the beginning of our
confidence steadfast to the end God
wants us to hold on to him until the end
and one of the verse Jesus said in
Matthew 24 he who endures to the end the
same shall be saved so to be a Christian
today requires endurance that he CR it
requires faith faith and belief in God
you know we do have a book that deals
with the subject it's can it's called
can a saved man choose to be lost just
that's the title can a saved Man chew to
be choose to be lost we'll be happy to
say that to anyone who calls and asks
you'd like to learn more about that
subject the number again is
800-835-6747 call and ask can a saved
man choose to be lost and we'll be happy
to send that to anyone in North America
who do we have next next we've got Keith
calling in from Michigan hi there Keith
what's your question
uh so the question I have is if as if
um Satan no longer has access to the
Tree of Life
um how is God sustaining him and how was
he not destroyed when the flood came
okay good question well we do know that
the angels are in a different dimension
than we are they are Spiritual Beings so
that means they don't have flesh and
blood as we do we do know that they have
abilities to appear and they can even
appear as dead loved ones they can
possess a person you call that demon
possession
um they can travel you know quickly they
can't read our thoughts but they can put
ideas in our minds so to speak the Bible
says only God knows the heart of man but
they can tempt us so they there is that
that Dimension that we can't see now I
think maybe before Adam and Eve sinned
they their eyes were open they were able
to see the Angels but Adam and Eve were
created unique they created in a
different format than the angels and by
them partaking of the tree of life that
was a symbol of their faith and
obedience in God and it sustained their
life here on the earth so the devil has
a different type of
life a different sustenance you might
say that preserves his life but the
clock is ticking the devil will be
destroyed his life can come to an end he
couldn't have been destroyed during the
flood because it's a spiritual being
although maybe the devil was afraid when
he saw everything happening here on this
planet the rain and the storm of the
volcanoes and everything else that was
happening but as a spiritual being he
can't be chained with the physical chain
or be bound or held physically so it's
just a different dimension than we are
but he will be destroyed
does that help Keith oh okay yeah it
does all right great thanks for your
call who do we have next
yeah next we have calling in is uh
Jonathan Jonathan another caller from
Tennessee hi there Jonathan are you with
us
take good evening I can hear you oh yeah
thanks for your call
hey good good enjoying the discussion so
far tonight hey uh so my question is
regarding uh kind of interpreting the
second coming of Jesus uh so I guess I
would phrase it this way didn't Jesus
lose his omnipresence on Earth
if so how is it that he will be seen by
every eye as it is stated in Revelation
1 verse 7. yes good question well when
Jesus comes the second time as he's
coming to the earth the earth is still
turning so the Bible doesn't say that
everyone's going to see Jesus at exactly
the same time but it says everyone on
the earth will see Jesus when he comes
so as Christ approaches the Earth and of
course Jesus is coming with all of the
Angels is going to be very dramatic and
glorious event as the Earth turns
everyone's going to see Jesus perhaps at
the second coming of Christ Jesus
circles the Earth before the righteous
are caught up to meet him we don't know
for sure how Christ is going to do that
but yes everyone living will be able to
see Jesus when it comes the second time
of course there's two responses the
righteous look up and they say this is
our God we waited for him he'll save us
the wicked turn to the mountains and the
rocks and they say fall on us and hide
us from the face of him who sits upon
the throne and from the Wrath of the I
am that's Revelation chapter six all
right thank you Jonathan who do we have
next
yes uh next we have a caller from Texas
I think it's a
Franklin fredlin is that correct
yes hello good evening hi welcome
hi thank you Pastor yes so my question
is earlier someone called in and they
were um asking about those do people or
you know Satan do they burn literally
forever but my question is in regards to
the degrees of punishment because I
always hear it said that you know some
people that have you know done greater
sins they burn for longer and I'm
thinking to myself
um I know the scripture does kind of
hint at that but how does that work if
we're all Mortal beings how does one
person burn longer than the other okay
well that's a good question let me give
you a verse maybe you can look it up for
me past Aaron Jesus says he who knew the
will of his master and did not do it
will be beaten with many stripes he who
did not know the will of his master and
did not do it will be beaten with few
Stripes so there are degrees in
punishment that's going to be meted out
for the wicked not everyone receives the
same reward did you find that yeah
that's Luke 12 47. Luke 12 47
um and the Bible does tell us in
Revelation that when Jesus comes
revelation 22 that he'll reward everyone
according to their work so they are
degrees they are varying rewards as far
as how will that actually happen
um well when the wicked are resurrected
at the end of the Thousand Years uh you
know I don't think they're going to have
exactly the same type of bodies that we
have now you know I don't think they're
going to have to go plant and find food
to eat and find water to drink it seems
as though they resurrected in a form
where they can actually see what's
happening in the Golden City they'll be
able to see the Angels they'll even be
able to see the devil so it's a little
bit of a different form than we have now
and apparently the fire that destroys
the devil and his angels it's not just a
regular fire because the devil can't be
burnt with the fire that we know today
so it's a special fire that purifies and
cleanses the Earth so it's going to be a
little different at the end of the
Thousand Years when the wicked are
resurrected yeah we know the the
ultimate punishment for all the wicked
is death right the wages of sin is death
I mean to use an example of today right
we in many uh places there's a death
penalty right there's different kinds of
ways that the punishment of death can be
inflicted right lethal injection
electric chair you know just being shot
so we know that the ultimate
punishment is death but the process to
get to that death can be different right
it can vary in intensity and duration so
how God's gonna do it exactly the Bible
doesn't tell the Bible doesn't tell but
we know that it's going to be just and
fair
absolutely well does that help a little
bit uh for Dean
yes it does actually um give me A New
Perspective I was thinking uh
we're cooking a chicken if you cook it
on low it takes a longer time to go to
the organs right yep but if you cook it
on a higher heat kind of like uh would
never could never when he would like
turn up the fire seven times hotter you
know it should kill them on the spot
right and it should get to their organs
faster than if it was on a lower heat so
sure I don't know um I just won't know
that part but at least we do know that
there is like uh different levels there
there is yeah good question now the good
news of course is none of us need to
have first-hand experience of that fire
right yeah because God has provided a
way of escape and we can praise him for
that we can receive him as our personal
savior who do we have next
yes we have uh chalk chakura I'm sorry
if I'm mispronouncing
calling in from Minnesota hi there what
is your question this evening
so in Psalms 82 6 it says that we are
God
um can you explain what that means okay
very good well let me read the verse
here for those of you who might not have
their Bibles in front of them it says
starting in verse 5 they do not know nor
do they understand they walk about in
darkness all of the foundations of the
Earth are unstable it says as oh I said
you are gods and all of you are the
children of the most high but you shall
die like men so the word that Gods can
also be translated as rulers or Lords or
those who might hold dominance over
others so of course God does hold that
position he is the ultimate ruler but
there were also others that claim
themselves to be rulers over others they
claim themselves to to be worthy of
recognition but the reality is they're
going to be destroyed that's what the
next verse says even if they are princes
it says them they'll fall one of the
princes so when God Rises up to judge
them so there's no so there's no Escape
even of those who claim to be in
positions of influence or power or Lord
over others
yeah it's certainly true that we are
made in the image of God and in the
likeness of gods who are like him in a
variety of different ways
all right does that help a little bit uh
shikari
Shakira and you've got it thank you
one time
[Music]
was a pastor and he said that his name
was Elijah
um Mighty God is that okay for us to say
um you mean the phrase almighty God yes
uh if we're referring to the god of
Heaven absolutely you know I think we
want to be careful you know the Bible
tells us don't take God's name in vain
and when we talk about God and we we
talk about the almighty God we want to
do that humbly and reverently we don't
want to do that in jest and that title
almighty God only belongs to one and
that is the Creator God that's the god
that we worship and serve so uh yes
there's nothing wrong in saying almighty
God but we want to do it reverently and
in the proper
um circumstance
all right who do we have next
what about Joe in New York Joe are you
there I'm glad you're there to help
people hi welcome to the program I had a
question about the Bible when it talks
about the same blinding the minds of the
people this world does that mean like
they were born blind and they can't see
till God waking them up or they choose
to be blind because it says it says
they're provisionist to them that don't
believe
or Satan keeps blinding them or he
blinded them before you were born like
when they're born or blinded you're
blaming him or what okay
of course
okay we're talking about spiritual
blindness here we're not talking about
literal blindness but uh when it talks
about the devil blinding a person what
happens is if you hear the truth if you
have access to the truth or the Holy
Spirit speaks to your heart and you
reject that you harden your heart very
often that gives access to the devil to
present a lie and in doing that your
heart is even hardened and you are even
more blind Jesus said of the religious
leaders of his day he spoke of them as
being the blind leading the blind now
he's talking spiritually because they
had rejected the truth that Jesus had
come to give they rejected the teachings
of the scriptures and they had their own
man-made traditions and they were
considered spiritually blind and so yes
if we reject truth our hearts are
hardened and we opening ourselves up for
more deception uh Paul actually says and
maybe you can find that verse because
they receive not a love of the truth God
shall send them strong delusions that
they shall believe a lie so if somebody
rejects truth their hearts are hardened
in disobedience
so hopefully that helps a little bit did
that make sense Joe
comes after the heart and heart or
they're born blind because they can't it
says a natural man cannot understand or
obey the things of God yes so we are
naturally born with a selfishness
towards self but God still speaks to us
and God tries to reach us because he's
not willing that any should perish but
he wants all to come to Salvation And
depending upon how we respond to that
how we respond to the promptings of the
Holy Spirit and the truth of God's word
that determines whether we going to
spiritually have our eyes open to see
more truth or are we going to be blinded
by the deceptions of Satan so it's what
our response is that gives access to the
devil I think we have time maybe for one
more caller who do we have yeah let's um
let's go with uh Frank calling in from
Montreal uh International caller hi
there Frank welcome thank you very much
thank you for taking my car you're
welcome so back to Creation did God
create death because God wanted break
into edema if he said if you eat the
food you will die I believe that was the
first time okay that was mentioned in
the bible yes the God create death well
the absence of life is death and the
Bible says God is life so whenever
somebody is separated from God or they
chooses to rebel against God the natural
consequence of that is death you know
I've heard somebody once explained it
that if you have a light and you have it
plugged into the socket in the wall and
you have electricity flowing through
you're going to have light the light's
going to shine but the moment you unplug
and you pull you know pull the plug out
from the wall there's no electricity
flowing and so the light goes out and
there's you're in darkness so if we plug
by faith into Christ if we are trusting
in God we have life especially eternal
life but if we reject Christ if we
reject eternal life the end result is
darkness and death so it's not that God
creates death death is just the natural
result of rebellion against God for
without God there is no life the only
other alternate would be death stay with
us we're going to take some Bible
questions in just a moment
[Music]
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
[Music]
Hello friends welcome back we have about
two and a half minutes for those of you
who are listening on land-based stations
we have to say goodbye to those who are
on satellite radio but those who are
watching on the internet and also
land-based stations we've got some of
your email Bible questions that have
come in and so we're going to try and
give an answer to as many of these
questions as we can in the next two
minutes what's the first question yeah
the first question we have here is what
will we be doing in heaven throughout
all of eternity all right sometimes
people think well is it going to be
boring in heaven are we just going to
sit on a cloud and play a harp no the
Bible says I Is Not Seen Nor Ear heard
neither has it entered into the heart of
man the things that God is preparing for
those that love him so we can't even
begin to imagine all of the exciting and
fun things we're going to be doing in
heaven we do know that we're going to be
building our own houses in the earth
made new and will be inhabiting them and
we'll be going up from one Sabbath to
another to worship before the Lord uh
we're going to have friendships we might
even be able to travel to other worlds
and uh travel through the universe so we
don't know the Bible doesn't tell us
exactly what we're going to do but if
the Bible does say it's going to be
better than you can even imagine what's
our next question yeah we have uh Judy
and she wants to know where in the Bible
does it describe angels having wings
okay well we have a couple of references
uh Revelation chapter 4 describes God's
throne room and it talks about these
four living creatures uh you're reading
Ezekiel they are spoken of as cherubim
and seraphim and they have six wings and
two wings that cover their feet two
Wings they fly two Wings they cover
their face so these are Angelic beings
and they have wings we also know that
the angel Gabriel when he appeared to
Daniel in response to Daniel's prayer
the angel said I was caused to fly
swiftly so apparently the angel can fly
we know Gabriel is an angel so yes there
are references to Wings in in the Bible
that these Heavenly beings have but
these wings are not the kind of wings
that we think of here that you need to
be able to Flap to to get airborne they
can fly in space
what do we have next yeah great answer
next question is why did God choose to
cast The Devil to the Earth
okay why did God choose to cast The
Devil to the Earth well he didn't choose
to cast The Devil to the Earth but when
the devil came and tempted Adam Eve the
devil claimed because Adam was given
dominion over the earth when Adam sinned
that Dominion passed from Adam to Satan
and Satan claimed the Earth as his
matter of fact Jesus said that the devil
is the prince of this Earth but when
Jesus died on the cross and he rose
again he became the second Adam now he
is our representative the devil has lost
that dominion and so he's here on the
earth going around like a roaring lion
friends thank you for joining us we look
forward to visiting again next week God
bless
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]